not as pretty as we'd like it to be nate
that's for sure but
hopefully skies are going to clear up as
we get into our last weekend of summer
we still have
wildfire smoke out there and that air
quality advisory for
smoke dust and elevated ozone is still
with us
through tomorrow lots of 70's around our
valley neighborhoods cooler up at kyle
canyon as you'd expect
in the 50s sally has made its way ashore
as a category 2 hurricane but she's
weakening we'll get there in a moment
and take a look
at her progress up to the west coast
we're seeing a little bit of rain
but that system is still staying
offshore
while hurricane sally slammed the gulf
coast
before daybreak this morning it is now
downgraded to a category one but it's
still got 90 mile per hour winds
and there have been areas that have been
pounded by 90 plus mile per hour winds
as well as two feet of rain at times so
flood warnings are in place there even
been tornado warnings because of sally
take a look at some of the video
that we've seen from overnight and you
can see that there's been so much
damage boats have been tossed around
there's been a lot of roof damage
and again so much catastrophic flooding
already
cars have been swamped homes have been
flooded and you can see the damage along
the shoreline
as well so we'll continue to follow
sally's progress but
again it's been a lot of damage along
the gulf coast and now flooding rains
up into alabama and georgia today all
right we're looking for about 102 today
we'll still keep smoke in the air
we'll call it mostly sunny but hazy
sunshine about 102
maybe even hotter tomorrow and then
breezy winds with that system out of the
pacific northwest moving inland
we'll pick up some southwest winds
especially in our local mountains
fire weather watches have been posted
there for thursday friday
upper 90s into the weekend our last
weekend of summer
fall officially arrives on tuesday good